Android patterns for performance
If there is one law of performance for everyone to follow,
It avoids unnecessary actions.
I'm Joanna Smith.
Although it sounds simple, you may face a challenge in locating places
Where your software instructions waste time on things that are not important.
Let me show you an example so you can imagine it,
It is excessive writing.
Overwrite occurs when you type your application for pixels on the screen
Just for another pixel or width to overwrite it later.
All this I did to add color to the pixel the first time
Is something totally useless.
It is a repair technique that is called screening
It means removing the code
Or the situation in which treatment time is wasted.
Sorting only takes you away from this
But from "Off" to "F".
To actually fix excessive writing problems,
Try isolating screen parts
Which you want to type but will not appear to the user
Then avoid typing it.
Since we are talking about this subject, we discuss the writing.
Write down objects writing time, memory and battery.
If possible, select views that will not participate in the final scene
Avoid typing and will retrieve some frame time,
Such as those that are overwritten when hidden
By another layer of objects.
But you also avoid writing objects
Which are outside the screen, because it is a complete waste of time and memory.
But for all objects blocked and off the screen,
Learn to multiply the story.
But sorting is not just for writing.
To think about searching a database for a user who meets several criteria,
Such as Texas residency, baldness and obsession with performance.
Some developers who lack imagination may start looking at the database from the beginning,
In each constraint a user is assigned an address in Texas
And about hair color is not applicable,
And about using the perfmatters label in the description of the profile.
But it takes a long time.
Smart developers will arrange queries
To reduce the group of users you need to search for
For each successive standard,
Such as isolating people baldness first.
We have just sorted out our list to a great extent.
Then they can remove each non-state address and no Texas postal code,
This makes us a much smaller user list.
All we need now is to run the expanded search
In their profiles for the perfmatters label
In this very small number of records.
So we found the person required.
Sorting is useful in everything from writing a UI layer
Through searching databases and accessing real-time services,
Such as location.
If your app, for example, alerts users based on local events,
Such as an Android Developer event that includes a barbecue party,
It is not logical to lose event updates
Outside the area where the user lives.
In each case, the basic principle remains the same,
It is checking the relevance of the thing before wasting time on it.
Because in most cases,
Costing the object more than takes enough time
To determine whether it should be treated at all.
So it took time to think about the user and what he cared about,
Then use the sort to help you focus on those things,
In this case, there is no gain.
Less effort in your app and a better experience for your users.
The screening is a good start
But performance is not limited to it.
So watch the rest of Android Performance Patterns
Consider joining the G + forum for tips, guidance, and help.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.